[Music]
in this problem which of the following
Technologies is best for removing
arsenic from wellwater to be used as a
domestic water supply the options are
granular activated carbon Sand
Filtration reverse
osmosis and ion
exchange okay so this is another concept
problem what that means is that there
isn't much in the reference manual
that's going to help us solve it in this
case I'll walk through what each
treatment type is
for granular activated carbon is useful
for removing organic contaminants like
volatile organic
compounds Sand Filtration is commonly
used to remove suspended solids and
sediments and may also be used as a
pre-treatment process for reverse
[Music]
osmosis reverse Osmos itself is used to
remove inorganic
[Music]
contaminants finally ion exchange is
commonly used for removing dissolved
ions such as heavy
metals so in this case we need to know
that arenic is an inorganic
element if we know that we can tell away
that our answer is reverse
osmosis now if this problem feels
annoying and unsatisfying to you because
you simply didn't know enough about the
subject matter don't let it get you down
there's going to be a number of concept
questions on the PE exam some you can
use the manual for and others you just
have to know you're not going to get
every problem right and that's okay also
the majority of the problems on the exam
are calculation based not
conceptual what you can do in the
meantime is use problems like this as a
small test of your current understanding
of this particular subject matter from
there you can look up additional
information about water treatment
Technologies and review some basic
information about each type so if you
didn't know the answer to this question
don't sweat it it's one out of 80 on the
exam and that's going to be it for this
problem